the average person who doesn't pay
attention to the news cycle doesn't hear
any of this stuff that's going on with
Joe there's the actual clip of him
saying I made this as a quid pro quo
quid pro quo in Ukraine and nobody knows
about it nobody cares because the
average person isn't paying attention
and that's who they've weaponized the
dumbing down of America through
corporate press yeah and I I actually
think teams I think it's somewhat
inverted I think people in this country
have been stupid for a long time I
should say ignorant uh because of mass
media you only got information from a
few sources and now with the internet
we're becoming more educated and
informed on what's happening but it's
targeted you're choosing where you're
getting your media from you or I or
everyone here may be privy to looking at
right and left-wing media the average
person doesn't do that and we just
thought we didn't have that 20 years
exactly the average person just follows
CNN because whether we believe CNN or
not they think that they're getting
informed by somebody from there or MSNBC
but it's even more targeted than it used
to be